you should not make sure the lighting is
very bright so because I am already so
old you cut out part that make me look
old okay I come from Vietnam but my
parent come from China
I'm originally from Philippines but I
live in San Diego I am from the the
friends are you ready
did you not eat Korea the fourth time
we've done yes that camera game take my
picture I look so pretty I might I do I
do modeling how cute I look cute doing
this is a cute girl in a ring is a cute
my mom can turn any situation or
conversation into a compliment about
herself President Obama did something's
like yeah he's very very organized like
your mother
see mother yes you are smart like your
mom hello hi Eugene oh wait you're me oh
okay did you eat yet
are you okay are you eating yes yes I
have to know okay I have to go now okay
I can't eat any money yes
always always send me anything mom do
you take my fish oil I buy for you from
Costco oh my god omega-3 oil it's good
for you she turns to my stepdad when
like oh my god he's always so busy mom
did you Facebook my friend oh my god oh
oh why you give me older you know the
kemper it's a genetic from you oh when
he go home mom I'm hungry and I have
some food you act like a baby around me
yeah Wiener face okay thank you like you
mom mom are you kidding me
can you cut that I don't why you drive
so fast dry slower my mom is all excess
and she's always like must be a woman
must be a woman Dragovic you have to buy
a new car Eugene when was last checkup
Eugene why is your car so dirty the
people over there watch the people she's
like must be an Asian woman driving I'm
like you don't want me to drive I think
that's my theory
hmm very American he talks too much
sometime he were funny here away play
hip hop solved in a restaurant or
whatever yes that would that would
really be great yes yeah my job is to
talk yeah all we want to eat boring
though we say I love you a lot that's
not a weird it's never weird now so
that's like did you forget to say
something and usually I'm with like a
lot of friends you team you know I love
you so much
your mom loves you more than anybody
okay say bye bye what do you say mom
look mom everything I do is a lot like
how she acts except the doctor watching
except I talk too much
yeah and I take off my clothes man you
seem coming down yeah do you dislike
that I take my clothes off for videos no
comment